alan cox sufre desde hace 35 años una
rara enfermedad incurable su vida está
limitada a las cuatro paredes de su
habitación
[Música]
soy prisionero de mi cama mi espacio
vital es muy limitado es mi vida ya no
es lo que era
cada día médicos enfermeras
fisioterapeutas y asistentes de salud se
turnan al lado de su cama para atender
sus necesidades
en 5 minutos le daré su pastilla en los
últimos dos años el estado de este
hombre de 58 años ha empeorado su dolor
es muy intenso cuando está sentado
incluso salir de su habitación en silla
de ruedas se volvió algo impensable con
la esperanza de conmover al presidente
escribió a emanuel makoun para pedirle
el derecho a morir a su manera y en su
país algo que la ley francesa prohíbe
actualmente ahora espera viajar a suiza
donde el suicidio asistido es legal para
los residentes extranjeros
no quiero morir como un vegetal
inconsciente de mi entorno es una
situación que la ex anestesista andiyán
conoce muy bien voluntaria de la
asociación por el derecho a morir con
dignidad acompaña regularmente a los
enfermeros terminales que luchan por el
final apacible de su sufrimiento para
ella las leyes francesas al respecto son
anticuadas se terminan en la sedación
paliativa puede durar días incluso
semanas mientras que con la muerte
asistida por el médico que proporciona
el medicamento que provocará la muerte
en cuestión de minutos todo el mundo
está informado los familiares y los
pacientes que son conscientes de su
entorno y pueden incluso cambiar de
opinión hasta el último momento
fue una opción a la que a la única que
espera acceder pronto hasta entonces
seguirá luchando por el derecho a morir
para él y para quienes así lo deseen